[Music]
joining us right now to discuss this and
it's not just an American power but
problem is Pierce Morgan host of Pierce
Morgan uncensored on Fox Nation Pierce
we were talking about this a little in
the break and on the five this is
getting worse and it's not just an
American problem did we start it
I would say yes but I would also say
that in Britain we've got the same
problem of the woke left trying to
dominate an agenda which means that
their rights for a tiny minority of
people are now supplanting the rights of
the vast majority and I want to ask when
I hear that poor mother there talking in
the way that she did I would have lost
where are the rights of girls and women
in all this debate why are women being
erased why is the word woman now an
offensive term when did we allow
biological males to dominate women's
sport and wreck it irrevocably
potentially when do we allow young girls
to be in some kind of locker room and
have biological males walking in and
de-robing in front of them when do we
let this happen and how can this be
happening just after the me too time's
up Campaign which went on for years and
was supposed to be all about protecting
women who is now protecting women and I
address this as much to other women as I
do to you or to men we can say as much
as we like about this but so many women
have been cowed into silence they're too
afraid to do what that mother did
because if they do put their head over
the parapet they get shot down and
called transphobic which is nuts you
think it's 1919 or we're living with the
Taliban in charge but it's not so the
administration is not just jumping on
the transgender side they are staying I
don't know straddling the fence listen
to what kjp said talking about this
thing or really not talking about listen
the Department of Education proposed a
rule as you know that gives schools the
flexibility to establish their own
Athletics policies and so while
establishing guard rails right to to
prevent discrimination against
transgender kids and that is something
that is incredibly important uh uh that
the president wants to make sure that we
also do that as well they can't figure
it out they want the school districts to
figure it out well they don't know
what's good well she also went on to say
that the issue of trans athletes and
women's sport is very complicated and
there's no easy solution no it's not
complicated and it's a very easy
solution you ban them Canada today in
cricket I know your favorite sport but
the Canadian national cricket team has
picked their first transgender cricketer
this is a cricketer who has a male until
two years ago was incredibly
unsuccessful never got anywhere near
International competition will now be
representing Canada what does that mean
Ryan that means that a biological female
has been deprived
for her country because a biological
male who was nowhere near good enough as
a man to compete at that level is now
considered an elite sportswoman it is it
is completely outrageous if I'm right
track and field got ahead of this and
and they said no that's not going to
happen some sports have done it all
sports should do it and by the way it's
not about being transphobic I want trans
people to have the rights to fairness
and equality that we all enjoy that
doesn't mean that in their campaign to
get those rights they damage and
diminish and Destroy women's rights and
so I say look in sport very simple you
have another category for Trans athletes
completely new category or they compete
against their biological sex as many of
them used to less successfully why this
is so easy to solve I wonder why we're
not in the UK they say this we want to
take it NHS doctors are told not to ask
trans patients their names because it's
rude intrusive and insensive according
to officials so you cannot ask them
their gender you cannot ask them their
names oh it's ridiculous I mean look a
little thing but when I fly on British
Airways obviously always British Airways
but when I've done British Airways there
used to always be a soothing monotone
British accent that would say ladies and
gentlemen welcome to your British
Airways flight now they're not allowed
to say ladies and gentlemen because
there might be somebody who identifies
as something else on the plane who might
or might not be offended to which I say
what about my right to be called a
gentleman what about a woman's right to
be called a lady when did those rights
get completely destroyed at the altar of
trans activism I want their rights to
fairness inequality but I want my right
actually to be called a man and a
gentleman I want women to be called
women I want girls to be protected I
want women's sport to be protected and I
think the vast majority of people in
America and Britain and other countries
agree with me but California is not only
doesn't agree with you they're suing a
district that says no we will tell your
parents if you're a 12 year old girl and
you want to be a 12 year old boy boy and
they're being sued that's the Chico
Unified School District well you've seen
this case of an 11 year old girl who
apparently was a little confused at
school and the school said right we
think that you you know you're secretly
wanting to be a boy we're going to help
facilitate that we're going to allow you
to identify as a boy at the school and
we won't tell your parents the parents
sued in a 100
000 that's how this is going to change
you're going to see a lot of lawsuits
because I've I'm a father of an 11 year
old girl I've got three older Sons but
11 year old girl that same age I watched
the interview with the mother and
daughter on Fox uh today I think it was
and what was striking this girl who had
been confused is now not confused at all
she's a girl that was Fox and Friends
right so that was your interviewer thing
and and I remember thinking right so
that's my point they are not emotionally
or psychologically or physically
equipped to make a decision about what
they want to be the parents should be
involved in that decision and the
schools hiding it from parents in my
view is a former state sponsored child
abuse what if your school had that
policy where your daughter goes to
school about not informing the parents
what would you do but they're completely
nuts I would identify as a raving
lunatic and I would go in there and I
would pull her out and I say she's not
coming back here until he stopped this
woke nonsense and most parents would
feel that way now the idea that my
daughter could somehow be a boy at
school and that was hidden from me as
her father I would find completely
outrageous and I think most parents
think that you know what I also would
think most teachers agree with you yes
and they are subjected to the teachers
unions it says you step out of line you
lose your ten you lose your position and
they don't get paid enough anyway too
much corporate American and I include
unions and all of that as well too much
corporate American corporate Britain and
corporate Canada and other countries
they're getting bullied into taking
positions on this stuff which tailor to
a tiny minority of activists and they
are forgetting about the vast majority
of people who actually lead Common Sense
life lives and who want basic principles
about the society they live in to be
upheld one New Jersey teacher came out
and said they were told by the school
district to hide the fact that a child
told them about they wanted transition
so what do you do if you're the teacher
you speak up and do the right thing you
lose your job the next day and the thing
is it's easy to say do the right thing
but when you got kids at home and you
got to make a living it's tough we've
had a clinic in London called the
Tavistock Clinic very Infamous Clinic
where they were performing these
surgeries on young kids who wanted to
transition what would have happened with
that 11 year old girl right who thought
she was a little bit confused it was
probably a bit of a tomboy remember
tomboys about how prevalent that was a
lot of girls would go through a phase of
being tomboys the idea that they would
then be seized by Society absolutely put
into a clinic and mutilated before they
had a chance to really even go through
puberty and work out for themselves what
are they actually going to be in life is
into me inhumane I don't know how well
you studied my biography before you come
on everybody 15 times right so I want to
be you right and you are you are the
Mick Jagger of Television presenters
you're the Duracell bunny you know the
man who never sleeps the man who always
works you are a template for all of us
you should just identify as a Duracell
bunny
well if I could finish myself
in fifth grade I declared I would not uh
I would not be interested in a girl that
wasn't good in sports like Tatum O'Neill
right in bad news Paris I don't know if
that you carry that yeah yeah right
Tatum O'Neill would have been forced to
be a guy of course all right of course
Joy I enjoyed your first appearance on
Laura Ingraham show I you know what she
wasn't what I expected
Laura is now identified and Brian kill
me just for today which if you think you
haven't heard a horrifying transition
enough this is as bad as it gets people
evidently it's okay to come on the show
without a tie on too well you know what
I took my lead from you because you
normally go al fresco when you're doing
these kind of shows right and then you
come up all tied up and I think now I
feel a little bit naked right you're not
naked
Pierce thanks so much for coming in
great to see you and I'll see you
hopefully next week I keep fighting the
fight on this stuff because this has to
be one seriously this is a cultural War
which is damaging the Integrity of
women's rights in sport in uh privacy in
safety all these things it has to be one
women and girls have to be protected
you don't I can carry on
another segment maybe coming up hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else